gone is doing his best Mikasa cosplay
right now
if the tyrantine has proved anything to
me it's that you want to get a girl get
her a nice scarf get him a nice golf as
well because this is this is so this is
so comfortable
what's up Brethren welcome back to
another episode of the trash taste
podcast I'm bringing back the intros
baby I'm with Brethren number two and
three can we get to monetize for that
for the wood I'm pretty sure it's close
enough oh dude I'm quitting YouTube if
that happens no no you're not no you're
not dude have we really gotten so
Puritan to the point where we can't even
say that anymore that's ridiculous on
YouTube yes I I've I've given up on
making money on YouTube via ad Revenue
holy [__] like my all like my last for
the last six months I think I have had
only one video that has not been
demonetized are you serious yeah on my
main Channel at least which is what if
you're wondering why I never upload
anymore unless I have a sponsor on it
that's why otherwise I would not make
any money on it but you know sometimes
you gotta take the L's with the L's
sometimes is it because do you think of
the anime content or do you think it's
just because like something else like
it's wearing it's always something
different there's like a million
different things
um sometimes it's some of the anime
content sometimes it's the language
sometimes it's the music but as long as
I have sponsorships I'm also very like
unwilling to compromise on the way I
want to make content yeah that's you
know as long as I have sponsors I'll
keep making videos
I didn't know it was still that bad
because like I definitely got the brunt
of that like you know when the first ad
Pockets thing happened but like yeah
I've been pretty good for the past year
or so I mean you never really got
affected that much right I know yeah
yeah I was it was really weird because I
you know when the whole apocalypse
happened everyone was like freaking out
yeah I was like man I'm pretty sure my
stuff should get demonetized
yeah that is true like I didn't get it
and I I was kind of waiting and everyone
was freaking out I'm like yeah yeah
let's hope we can't get angry I'm like
my stuff's so green stuff meanwhile he's
like Scrooge mcducking through his money
I'm like oh here's another yowie video
please yeah but then you just figured
out that yowie was something that they
should demonetize and right then I I the
videos just stopped getting views as
well yeah yeah of course yeah my heart
being in the one percent I'm gonna tell
you that right it's hard okay my safe
Works after my second Channel that's why
I actually have to give it actually I'm
actually getting more videos demonetized
on my second Channel that I am on my
Mains because you're making anime
see why do you think I stopped making
anime content YouTube just doesn't like
anime
that's why everyone to stop and that's
why everyone stopped making anime
content about me basically horrible but
uh yeah you guys got to go to my home
country yeah we went to Thailand we just
came back from Thailand didn't really
post much about it
um just kind of went there I kind of
like invited you guys at very very last
minute to come yeah luckily you guys
were free
yesterday for like three days yeah I
think three days was the perfect amount
yeah really I wanted to be there a
little bit longer I mean I because we
because we only really got to explore
like kind of like I feel what is kind of
like a corner of Bangkok yeah with the
super touristy stuff we did yeah which
is fine because it's like that's how you
get introduced to it of course it's
through the touristy stuff yeah yeah I
don't know taking more than three days
off of work oh my God
yeah bro you literally cycle for eight
days what are you talking about yeah I
know but that was work though
if he's not if he's not filming it all
right well technically I filmed the Vlog
so I did yeah
I don't know what your excuses yeah no
but it was great
um yeah I feel like no I I kind of agree
like we did kind of go to all the
touristy places but I think that just
made me want to stay for a little bit
longer I think like next time before
where to go I definitely want to maybe I
mean I don't know what's anything else
I kind of like took you to like let's
say the more pristine clean areas uh
next time you're in Thailand we'd love
to say you to some of them all like
back-ends let's say like dirtier places
yeah because you can get a lot of
interesting things there
um do you guys have like a lot of like
islands and stuff like that oh yeah
there's a lot of the big tourist
destinations are they're like really
pretty Islands oh yeah that's I think
that's what I want to do now yeah yeah
sure yeah me too me too yeah I'll join
you on that one yeah hell yeah I I it
was an interesting experience from like
the moment we got off the plane it felt
very different this is the first time
I've gone to a country in a while where
uh I wasn't able to speak the language
the language remotely so yeah you know
because we've been doing America and
Japan which is like okay I know how to
talk in Japan yeah yeah so it's kind of
weird going to a place and being like
that guy again who couldn't he literally
was like please speak English I please I
felt bad but it was what it was but like
you get off the plane and immediately I
think American uh immigration has ruined
immigration for me which is I was
terrified right I was conditioned by
America to be terrified yeah and when we
get to the passport gate they literally
look at the passport for like one second
like get in yeah go go get inside with
you yeah in Thailand because like so
much of our economy is tourism I'm just
like that dude yeah I don't even like
did they even ask me
no question the dude didn't even talk to
me he
silently grabbed my passport looked at
it looked at my face stamped
I was like damn I should just say I'm
working let's see what happens
this [__] felt too easy America I gotta
ask questions just go to the toilet
was the line long when you were when you
got in no it was super it was super
quiet and uh then then I then the
question was like oh [__] it's not
America I can't like Uber or I can't do
anything right it's like [__] I don't
have any money I don't have anything I
gotta take a taxi yeah yeah so we were
like [__] what do I do with the cabs and
I also don't have a SIM card I don't
have anything so I went over to the SIM
card right it was like three of them
they all look really sketchy I'm not
gonna lie yeah and uh I I'm like can I
have two SIM cards please it was like 10
bucks each yeah and like yeah sure could
be your passport and then they would all
whip out their iPhones and start taking
pictures of my passport I'm like wait
what is what are you what is this
why are you ripping out iPhones what is
this I I was really confused I was like
what what's the were you guys taking
pictures for they're like oh we just
have to do this I'm like oh you're just
hot you know I don't know that's the
same boy and then I was like okay okay
and I was like can I pay by car they're
like cash only I'm like that's weird
um we're in an airport okay it's fine
it's fine I'll get some cash and then
come back give it to them yeah and then
I I'm like all right got my SIM cards go
to get the taxi and I'm pretty sure I'm
getting ripped off right away yeah okay
because I I'm it's like they they want
to charge me uh something like 60 bucks
like USD right I know from from what
I've heard from Thailand that's that's
in Thailand that's extortional yeah it
is and I was like but will the taxi be
there right away and will will it be a
big taxi because there's like there's
like a group of us and they were like
yes I was like scam me take my money bro
you paid 60 bucks for a taxi in Thailand
I think it was like 48 USD which is 100
ripoff but dude we literally rocked out
right away and it was all ready together
yeah I think that's no question because
when I heard that from Connor right
again this is America corrupting my mind
I was like oh 60 bucks for like what is
it like a 40 minute like taxi ride I'm
like all right yeah that's fine it was a
big van it was like a big van that could
you know obviously fit all of us yeah um
but so you know in my head I was like
okay yeah I mean that's not too bad but
then the second time we got onto the
taxi and the guy
and I saw 30 Baht was the starting price
I'm like it's like 80 cents yeah it was
like a 30 minute cab ride was like 10
bucks I was like what the [__] not even
it was like it was insane yeah it sounds
like Japan could never yeah I mean like
uh first rule when you come if you ever
come to Thailand and pretty much every
Southeast Asian country
um if you get a taxi meter only like if
if you really really need to they will
try to like get a fixed price yeah I
noticed this yeah I'm trying to do I get
it I look white as [__] I got it you
should scam me yeah like he would I was
like Hey I'm going here and he just said
something I didn't get it I was like
he's like three or something guys
afterwards who's asking for like five
times the price up front and then I
think like at one point we split up into
two taxis Joey went and then I went yeah
we all went the same direction and I
told him I wanted I wanted the meter
yeah he paid the 300. my thing came like
a hundred or something yeah so I paid
like a third of what Joey to be fair
that 300 Baht uh taxi ride I remember
because we were heading to uh the big
markets I forgot what the name of it was
uh yeah that one right um so we were
heading there
um and I told the guy that you know we
were heading there and this guy clearly
was very excited right right that it was
like oh he's taking a tourist right yeah
so he was trying the entire 30-minute
taxi ride this guy was trying so hard to
sell me on this Market that we were
heading but the only thing he could say
was 14 Market 14 market
and he would just repeat that for 30
minutes and I'm like yeah I get a borrow
there's 14 of them I get it and then
every time I would respond he'd just
laugh and Go Thailand happy happy
and I was like I'm like yeah you see you
seem very happy about it yeah but uh
yeah no it was like I think that's like
one thing about like that I guess uh if
you can call it the Southeast Asian like
living experience right it's like
everyone's just so chill and it's just
like so happy that you're there they're
like because you know you very rarely
get anything like that in Japan right
like maybe in Okinawa right you would
get someone that talkative and that like
people are trying to express people
yeah yeah that's that's one of the big
reasons why I moved out of Thailand
after living there for like three four
years yeah nothing done
I noticed as well dude people just don't
indicate ever
yeah they seem like a pointless thing
like this dude we were like an hour ride
didn't touch his [__] indicators once
they would either not touch the
indicator or when say they wanted to
Signal going into the left lane yeah
they would flick the indicator on for
half a second yeah
like no one saw that literally literally
the mood when you're driving into
Ireland it's just like who's gonna stop
me who's gonna stop me because because
literally you just have to like go yeah
yeah I swear it makes traffic slower
because everyone's being selfish yeah
and it's just slowing everything down
the moment the taxi just starts driving
off I can just see the objective survive
yeah it's so scary to be in the front
it's like you are getting tantalizingly
close to these like especially the bikes
as well oh my God I mean like I knew
southeast Asia had a lot of bikes right
because you know I've been to the
Philippines yeah but like Jesus Christ
these bikes are [__] speed demoning
through these like trucks and all these
taxis you know avoiding the lanes and
stuff like that I'm like how does how do
you how does anyone survive oh I mean
like it's just like it like I said in
Thailand and mostly Southeast Asian
countries you just need Ultra instincts
yeah she's like to like survive right
because this like you are constantly
just checking every mirror possible
because it's not the cars you need to
worry about it's the motorcycle oh yeah
okay I don't you know what I don't in in
the in the uh environment of driving in
Thailand I don't care if a car doesn't
indicate that's just normal you know
um but if you're changing a lane there
is you you always have this Instinct
that there is going to be a motorcycle
driving pass or a motorcycle doing
something bro some of these taxi drivers
have like the periphery of a deer like
they just like they can see behind
without looking back it's like yeah I
can see I can sense two bicycles
concerning about the lack of indicating
is like holy [__] if you're driving on a
motorbike my God you're just praying
that people aren't being dicks yeah
exactly and honestly like it's
Thailand's one of those like Michael's
one of those cities where you risk
people risk their lives daily going on
motorcycles me included uh because the
traffic's so bad yes right and uh
there's some sometimes there's just no
system in place right now bangkok's
still very much a developing City yeah
uh especially with this public transport
that sometimes uh you choose getting
stuck in a traffic jam for two hours or
it's a 20 minute taxi ride which one are
you gonna take and you're like well I'm
risking my life life but that 20 minute
taxi right that 20 minute motorcycle
ride looks damn appealing right now man
ain't gonna lie
um but yeah did you guys go on like the
tuk-tuks as well yeah
that was interesting because again like
it was like a five minute ride and the
dude was like 300. I was like I was like
dude I'm like yeah this this looks like
it weighs 10 pounds there's no way the
guess the gas usage in a year is
probably not even 10 bucks what are you
talking about I saw I remember the first
time we wrote the talk talks at night
like Connor did like a full one game
move and the guy was like 300 but
obviously you know we couldn't all fit
into one talk talk yeah I can only see
maybe like what three people at most
yeah so we had to get two talks and
Conor did like a big movie where he's
like all right let's do a package deal
yeah 500 for two well originally I was
like 200 and even then I know 200 is too
much stuff yeah I'm like hey you can
scam me but just give me this I just
want to bother yeah I actually feel like
I belong here yeah yeah I bought it with
him yeah obviously I knew I was getting
ripped off yeah I was like 200 and he
was like no uh 250 and I was like 250
for both and he's like all right sure
then he shout to the dude who had no
affiliation to him behind him being like
we're taking them both for 250 yeah I
didn't know what the guy said but I
could make it out pretty much he said
follow me and make 250.
he didn't tell him where we were going
to follow me and holy [__] these things
felt dangerous dude oh they are no seat
belts you're holding on for dear life
the dude's going like 60 miles an hour
and you're like holy [__] this is cool
but oh my God I'm gonna die I don't know
if you saw but like before we went on to
those two talks there was like a group
of about six people in front of us right
and I thought we had to wait a little
bit right because I saw like you know
while we were driving on the road these
talk to you know maybe fit two people on
average right maybe three if you
squeezed in but there was a group of
about six of them they all got into one
tuk-tuk and they're just like he
literally cramped in this tiny little
thing and they're like yeah a hotel
please I'm like bro
turn into a clown car dude sometimes it
is extremely tightly packed and I was
like that I mean it's dangerous already
yeah yeah and that felt like why not why
not add more risk yeah because I've seen
like entire families get on these like
motorcycles you know like yeah they put
like their two children at the front and
the the parents are sitting on and then
uh on top of that they have their
shopping on their like motorcycles they
are packing these things up to the brim
I I it's just it just I think what blew
my mind for one was just not only the
sheer amount of motorcycles that are on
the road but also just like how casual
people are driving these things through
that environment like I remember I saw
you know usually when you're on the back
of a motorcycle right yeah the first
thing is like you know make sure you're
sitting in front you know holding on to
the driver right yeah maybe wearing a
helmet if you want to be extra careful
yeah I remember
wearing a helmet no first of all no one
was wearing a helmet second of all I
remember I saw this woman who was
sitting to the side not holding on to
anything just looking at a phone what
the [__] oh no meanwhile this
motorcycle's just it's just sitting
there like yeah all right tell me
like you know like Jason Bourne like
really like Chads in the movies when you
see the stunts he's doing on a
motorcycle yeah
that's a nice ride yeah that's that's a
pretty cool motorcycles yourself yeah
that's actually a pretty normal way for
women to sit on the motorcycles because
a lot of times if they're wearing skirts
right like uh you know they want to they
want to sit kind of like that because it
looks a bit more elegant and they don't
need to like but like at least you know
like if I if I had to sit like that I
would at least like hold on to something
this one was just freehand one hand on a
phone she looks like she was waiting for
a doctor like you know it was just the
most casual like yep all right uh I know
my life's in danger right now but I
really gotta check Twitter you know I
just there's this bang it's weird I have
to retweet this right now yeah I mean
like it's it's definitely like no matter
how much I have described it in the past
there's nothing that I can like
replicate the feeling of just the
insanity
Southeast Asian roads and just how the
rules work over there
um it's it's a free throw and it's
always been a free-forow and and kind of
like every taxi you go to especially
especially if you're gonna if you're a
foreigner they're gonna try to battle
with you and they're trying you're gonna
try and get the best price possible oh
yeah dude everyone you've got us that
taxi dude it was like at the moment they
saw us wanting a cab like yeah 20 dude
spawned they were all shouting
was like I don't know who you were
talking to I think you were talking to
the crowd and you were just like no no
no it was weird it was just like God was
like I want a taxi yeah yeah it wasn't
until a lot later maybe because I was
drunk but it wasn't until a lot later I
realized that they were all taxi drivers
I thought I thought we were just getting
jumped by like 20 dudes I was like God
you're okay and I was like oh they're
all taxi drivers yeah because like what
happens is obviously uh I took the um I
took them to a place called Asiatique
which is
which is like a really nice bougie place
right by the river uh in Bangkok uh but
they needed to go home uh to the hotel
and so I know how it works you go over
they see a group of tourists and like a
group like a group of NPCs basically
will just support you know and and uh
one of them comes up and goes like Oh
300 Baht and I'm like
if you are willing to speak yeah I'm
like I am not a Taurus I I will not even
attempt to like take this number can
anyone say give me a better number and
as soon as I as soon as I just ignored
the guy two other dudes would be like
well we'll do it for half the price and
I remember I remember like uh turning
back to Conor and I'm and I'm like is
this price I gave for you and Connor's
like go go a bit lower go a bit and so
I'm like I'm like okay I'm like
bother them yeah I was like I want to
see how good this bothering is right
yeah yeah and so uh Conor's like get it
lower and I was like actually I did not
even she passed by the way no no no no
no no you just don't want to be ripped
because the time I didn't want to have
to deal with change anyway I was like
just [__] just yeah okay so so this
is what do they see how much he could
bother them I was I was curious for me
yeah sometimes you seem like I'm like no
I will not pay five bucks for taxes no
because uh like the thing is no matter
what price if if you agree on a price
basically if you could agree on a fixed
price it's always going to be higher
than the metered price no matter what
otherwise it or not like it was like a
10 not even 10 like a seven minute
Journey it would have been like 50 on
the meter yeah exactly so no matter what
you agree to so it's kind of like the
price you agreed to to just have the
convenience of of of just being like I
can't be asked to deal with this
[__] let's just like agree for a
prize just yeah it's basically paid away
so yeah Conor Conor I I kind of did them
a bit dirty a little bit because I'm
like bro come on I'm tired man come on
dude do me a favor do me a favor man
like you know you can you can go a
little bit lower because uh in Thailand
and I'm sure most other Southeast Asian
countries if you're speaking that
language and if you're off their
nationality then they're gonna they're
gonna do it a little bit lower so I'm
like do for your bro man do you for a
brother and he's like all right two
taxis just for you for that price that
you want I'm like cool and I'm like all
right boys get in the taxis and I'm like
like pushing them to get in the taxis
and then everyone gets in the taxi me
and Sydney are staying in another place
because we're going back home and he's
like are you not getting in I'm like no
just take my friends
I'm like
yeah but that's that's yeah that's kind
of like especially especially like the
tourist culture in Thailand you know
there's there's no 50 as well there's no
50 note they have a 20 note oh there
there is there's a 52.
yeah see this once really yeah I did not
have any these are mythical things I
never saw oh dude I I I've collected
those like Pokemon cards
every time the the ride was we agreed on
like 150 yeah I was like what I can't
ask him for 50 change after I just
bottomed him down I feel kind of cheeky
you know what I mean really so I would
just like just just keep the 200. it's
fine I don't know I was like
it's like I know you're already ripping
me off I think we bought uh at one point
as well that we bought the most
expensive Pad Thai oh really oh yeah we
got we got scammed 100 and I know if you
if I told you I paid best month for a
pad thai I think you'd kill me how much
I don't think I paid for Pad Thai mind
you mind you it was it was it was four
probably you know like maybe that big I
didn't know how big the past it was a
family size I didn't know how much the
pad thai was until after I bought it and
I was like excuse me
150.
very cute guys I paid we paid 750 for a
pet shop
oh my God
I I knew when we paid it I the only
thing I felt bad about is like God's
gonna be so ashamed yeah I didn't mind
because I was like hey I don't mind
getting scammed a little bit yes the
food was good it was great it was good
Pad Thai to be fair I mean all of it was
good yeah I don't think I had a bad
maybe you'd thought it was bad pad thai
too all right I mean Pad Thai is like
pretty hard to uh [__] up because uh pad
thai is the like I guess it's like the
most kind of like uh common dish
especially when tourist comes in that
they want to try uh when I was like
trying to show you right I was trying to
find a store and a store that actually
did some of the noodles that I liked but
every store was like no we only do Pad
Thai here and I'm like okay we're in a
touristy area uh I wanted to show you
guys some other like more spicier maybe
less no noodle dishes especially like
Drunken Noodles for some reason well
I'll try that yeah and unfortunately uh
Drunken Noodles are normally so uh sold
where there's a lot of like dirty bars
and stuff like that which we didn't go
to that time but uh next time hopefully
next time this episode is sponsored by
boxu guys it's approaching the end of
winter and you know what that means what
does it mean Sakura season is just
around the corner baby soccer season yes
yes and the best way to celebrate Sakura
season this year is with a boxer
companion but what is a boxu I'll tell
you boxer delivers the experience of
tasting authentic Japanese snacks
candies aunties sourced directly from
centuries old small family businesses
right to your door their mission is to
empower Japan's traditional snack makers
by sharing the authentic food and
stories with the world it looks so
delicious look at all the Sakura what's
in the box gone break it open oh yeah
send me black sesame listen to this
listen this boys
oh my God this is delicious succulent oh
yeah well you know what I'm also glad
I've already done an integration on my
own channel because I get to eat the
Sakura Mochi again I feel Heavenly if
you're jealous of them and you want your
own Sakura celebration and supporting
this channel click the link in the
description and use our code trash taste
to get 15 off your boxer order thank you
to boxer for sponsoring this episode
this episode is sponsored by Harrys you
see this beard that I have grown right
here it's pretty disgusting I know you
don't have to tell me in the comments
and for the longest time I was thinking
to myself damn why can't I find a good
razor that can get rid of all of this
disgusting man fluff well luckily for me
I found the perfect solution it's called
Harry's Harry's delivers razors right to
your door with refills when you need
them and you won't have to replace your
blade very often they're a sharp on the
eighth shave as they are on the first
the trim and shave trial set is a 15
Valley for just three dollars at
harrys.com trash taste it includes a
Fireblade German an engineered Razer
weighted handle foamy shave gel and a
travel cover plus you can schedule
replacement blade delivery whenever you
need them with refills as low as two
dollars my boys upgrade to a Razer and
skincare routine that will have you
looking your best with Harry's get a 15
Truman shave Trail set for just three
dollars by going to harrys.com trash
taste that's harrys.com trash taste for
a three dollar trial set back to the
episode but yeah the reason these two
boys came to Thailand to visit and
everything was because uh I finally 100
did my wedding guys my third one is done
it's all done now all of the family is
appeased no one is complaining anymore
with everyone has had a chance to go he
has all the Collectibles I have I
literally have I collected them all now
everything everything
um but it's it's funny because
this uh we decided to do like a
traditional like of like a traditional
Thai ceremony we could have just had
like the reception everything like that
but my parents were like no
um we want to do the traditional Thai
ceremony just because you've never seen
it yeah so even though I'm like talking
like about the Thai ceremony and this is
your guys's first Thai ceremony it was
also my first Thai ceremony as well
that's interesting yeah yeah it was cool
like it was I don't know it was a lot
more I guess not free-flowing it's not
the right word I guess more casual than
I thought it was going to be because
like I'm because you know I've been to
like traditional Japanese weddings right
and that's like you know a 500 page
script that you have to follow right
yeah whereas like this one felt like
yeah like as you said it was a wedding
of course but it was more like just a
celebration of like family getting
together and just like shooting the [__]
yeah which I think I really appreciated
because like I was expecting it to be
like really super uptight and like very
formal and you know they were like
obviously very formal parts of it like
the the Buddhist monk thing was like
super freaking cool yeah um but then you
know I had to do like 10 push-ups for
you as well which was weird yeah so to
to explain everything that kind of went
down at this wedding so uh normally you
start off in the morning and normally
the morning is the part where you do the
serious kind of blessings that's right
uh we started off at about like like
before before anything actually these
two boys asked me what do I wear do I do
I wear a suit or something like that or
Thai yeah and I was like no uh wear a
Hawaiian shirt Hawaiian shirts shorts
and thongs
speaking my language exactly I mean it's
it's it's hard enough in Thailand man we
were like no nobody wears suits we're
going like all casual the only one who
really wore kind of a more traditional
Thai attire uh was me and Sydney so we
had gotten dressed early in the morning
and even then
what I wore in My Thai wedding compared
to what I wore in my you know other
wedding uh in England was a lot less
layers it was just one kind of like
traditional Thai suit yeah and like very
very airy and baggy pants is cool they
were actually really comfy yeah I kind
of like after I like they I had the
opportunity to get changed earlier in
the day but I was like I don't like this
I kind of like this ride now it looks
really cool yeah yeah
um but one thing I kind of like wasn't
prepared for actually was uh uh this was
like my the only time that I had got my
makeup done yeah I noticed you're doing
makeup and I was like wow God looks like
he's been airbrushed yeah okay yeah is
wearing makeup like a traditional thing
or is that sound like your mom was like
hey I got you hooked up honest you look
like as [__] bro let me fix it yeah I
think I think uh for Thai weddings you
they most people wanted to look as good
as you can in photos and everything like
that but the difference is most people
don't trust themselves some make
themselves look as good as they can
um so my mum hired like a makeup artist
and then the day before she was like Oh
no you're getting your makeup done as
well I'm like what what do you mean I'm
getting my wake up done and uh so yeah I
got my makeup done I think God damn it's
I gotta say he was eyebrows on fleek
girls
respect to you girls man holy [__]
makeup is uncomfortable oh that was
awful wait so you got just like I think
you got like your cheeks done and like
your eyes a little bit and the lip gloss
as well the lip gloss was the thing that
like annoyed me the most oh yeah yeah
you look like an ad
yeah so I got I got ready and got my
makeup done in the morning and then the
monks came at around 10 o'clock
um and their ceremony they're you know
praying blessing ceremony lasts for
about 30 minutes to 45 minutes and
basically they kind of just pray and
give Their Blessings and everything like
that I mean you boys it was very cool
yeah well they started uh singing that
was pretty hype yeah that was [__]
cool it was so cool yeah because I I
remember we were having this like
ceremony and obviously Sydney's parents
and family were there as well and uh my
dad was like oh the my my uh Sydney's
mum and dad was like oh that was such a
beautiful part to uh such a beautiful
ceremony to be a part of thank you for
inviting us and showing us part of your
culture and everything and then Sydney's
uncle was also there and he just goes to
me man those monks got bars
I was like yeah yeah but it's it it
makes sense it makes sense because
um I didn't realize this when I was
because you know I've been a monk and
everything like that I didn't realize
this but there's a certain Rhythm
rhythmic quality wow when they are
praying and everything uh because you
know there's how it works is there's is
only one head monk that starts off a
verse let's say and they they say a few
sentences they chant a few sentences of
this verse and then everyone else joins
us afterwards yeah and it's kind of it
the whole reason why Buddhist monks pray
is not because we're praying to a god or
anything like that because we don't have
a God in Buddhism but it's it's kind of
to get us in the rights mindsets to
meditate to be a monk and everything and
with I kind of realized after talking to
Sydney's mum and dad why
the prayer kind of has this effect
because when you're praying when you
have that kind of rhythmic prayer going
on for like an hour sometimes your mind
kind of goes into this hypnotic stance
State it's like a trance it's like a
trance yeah kind of and then that gives
you that gets you into the right mindset
to live the monk life and to meditate
afterwards as well
um and yeah I think it's I'm really glad
you've always got to experience it
because it can be like a very powerful
experience sometimes because that was we
had 10 monks in just my house but in a
temple uh especially when I was among we
had a we had a temple with a hundred
monks that sounds crazy yeah so you're
in you're in the temple when this
massive hall and then yeah you hear the
you hear the head monks start praying
and in my mind in my temple we needed to
know all of the prayers by heart right
so I needed to memorize them so I need I
knew when when the head monk started
starting a line I would know when to
come in and I would know when to start
praying as well and you all join in and
the ambience and the sounds that just
vibrates throughout the entire Temple
it's something like some something I
can't really explain via words but it it
feels really really powerful oh yeah
even even just with the 10 monks in in
your house like it was yeah I mean like
it just the fact that everyone was just
you know very silent and a lot of us
were like closing our eyes and you know
um just trying to like take it all in it
was like yeah I don't know it felt very
otherworldly you know it was uh because
you know because Japan has a similar
thing as well yeah and like funerals and
stuff like that uh but yeah every time I
hear I don't know what it is every time
I hear that sound it just puts me like I
can just feel my body floating away if
that makes sense you know it's just
something about it and you don't even
have to like know the words yeah at all
either I mean they're not even speaking
Thai oh really it's like it's uh I think
the language is like Sanskrit I don't
know what the English translation name
of it is but it's it's like an ancient
language so okay yeah they're not
actually they're not actually chanting
Thai it's uh it's a more older language
which is why you need to memorize it
right um which is why I need to memorize
it because I don't actually know what
they're saying it's it's an basically I
I would say it's more equivalent to them
chanting Latin if we were in like
European language right yeah I was
trying to figure out when when I was
supposed to pray I was like everyone's
face in their eyes okay okay yeah
yeah so I want to be respectful guy was
just sitting there while I'm so like I'm
like all right well yeah yeah even
though I don't personally you know
believe in it yeah I still like to
respect in the culture especially if
they're inviting me yeah no it was yeah
I remember that actually it was so funny
because you know when they started
chanting and you know most people in the
room were you know signed to pray yeah
and and I joined in and I remember
halfway through I looked up and your mom
is just standing there with me phone
like this yeah
just seem like Unstoppable and like it's
like no matter what is happening they
will be doing what they want to do yeah
it could be like the most important
thing ever and they'll be like guys get
closer I'm taking a shot you know it's
like whoa there's like what oh wow
it's such a power move no I'll I'll
definitely get to that point because I
being that definitely reminded me of one
thing uh which I'll get back to but um
yeah one I at the moment at the
beginning I was trying to like tell
Sydney everything that she had to do
everything she could expect with the
monk thing and then when when the mouse
got there I'm just like just follow my
lead Sydney there's too much going on
because there's one thing I forgot to
tell her about which is at the end
um we light a candle uh for the Monk and
the monk like melts this wax onto like
um a bowl of water which they will then
kind of like spray onto US oh yeah right
um I knew this was going to happen
because there's uh what do I call it
like I not exactly spray but there's a
bunch of like sticks bundled up together
that will they were dipped into the
water they will pray bless the water
then can I flick it into like the onto
the crowd sprinkle yeah like sprinkle
sprinkle uh Sydney didn't know this uh I
I knew this was coming so I've done this
ever since I was kid and I and so I knew
when when the when you when the monk is
about to kind of uh spray everyone just
put your head down put your head down
Sydney Sydney didn't know this so she
was she was just praying in like a very
nice kind of mindset gets a face full of
water from the market she's like she's
like Madame too soon because like we
were we were kind of in the back of the
whole thing when it happened and of
course none of us knew that was coming
out here so I'm just like you know
silently closing my eyes and praying and
then I get the AOE splash down
and I'm like is this test like is am I
am I supposed to just like remain calm
and then everyone's just getting like
splashed you didn't get it at all right
no I didn't I heard like didus and you
kind of make a noise yeah cause I was
behind you so I didn't get anything like
that yeah so you're you're in uh you're
in the spouse
yeah that's a wide AOE dude oh my God
and then there was a there's a few other
ceremonies and stuff and uh there's one
thing with like your elders or something
yeah so
um so after the monk thing
um there's this ceremony uh then we get
to the fun part there's a ceremony which
um is called uh Gun Mark which how can I
describe this ceremony the best way I
can describe it it's kind of like
replicating old ancient traditions where
you present the groom to the household
of the brides right
um so what happens is uh you separate
the two households you separate the two
families which is what we did Sydney's
family was in my house and we had walked
to our neighbor's house yeah and if you
can call that a house if you can call
that a house yeah some some of our
neighbors got pretty wild with their
house more like a Disneyland looking
Place yeah it was kind of wild yeah I
was like what the hell yeah and so what
happens is
um you separate the two houses you have
the groom side and you have the bride
side and the whole concept is all the
groom side has to come together to help
the groom kind of be able to prove to
the bride's family that they are worthy
to marry the bride right
um it was basically an escort Mission it
was an escort Mission thought like we
went my parents went full like force
were there where they
um they hired like traditional dancers
and like traditional like musicians uh
so we separated the houses and then you
started off with like kind of like a
king kong Tarzan kind of chance yeah you
know
by the front day we had like some
traditional Thai dancers it felt super
weird yeah I'll I'll be honest crazy
you're so fun though they were just like
go here guy yeah I was like what am I
doing yeah I don't know what I don't
know what the [__] is yeah economy
indictis were given like a Play-Doh like
desserts or something we're just like
hold this and I'm like I don't know
what's happening and then the drums
stopped playing I'm like oh okay I guess
we're going yeah and so basically my
boys just escorted me to the the bride's
house yeah and so you stop at the gate
um and I thought I was meant to talk uh
but no my mother my mother was
apparently doing the one this is your
this is your mom's honestly it's like
step aside Sunday
and she basically she has to kind of
like negotiate uh with the households to
kind of like to kind of like let us into
the house right and uh with this
procession there are like there are
three gates and there are different
trials that we need to do at each gate
and these trials are picked like kind of
not really at random but I guess peaked
by like the the whoever's house oh yeah
the bride's house so there are different
like how it traditionally is
um because families are so big you'll
have different members of the bride's
house uh guarding each gate and they
will ask the groom to do whatever they
desire and this there's not like there's
not anything on paper where you know
traditionally you need to do this it's
just whatever they feel like asking for
right it's kind of like yourself yeah
kind of like a little forfeit basically
yeah right and so at the first Gates
um my family I was asked uh to shout you
know I love Sydney as uh loud as I can
bear in mind there's like 100 people
like crowding around yeah yeah this is
like a lot of people yeah this is a lot
of people you get escorts of the first
gate
um you get asked I got asked the shout
out I love Sydney so she can hear uh she
she can hear me because Sydney right now
she's not outside she's inside the house
right that's how that's how it's meant
to be it's kind of like kind of like
you're with your Bros and you're
invading a castle you know that's that's
kind of how it's meant to feel West Side
Story yeah
I remember saying it's like oh it kind
of feels like we're storming a castle
right now but there's a lot of people
yeah there's a lot there's a lot of
people uh I'm sure your neighbors just
joined in yeah yeah I don't even know
who these people were yeah yeah yeah uh
that was pretty easy and then the second
one
um the second the second game was a bit
more tricky because uh my family member
was like you got you're not doing this
alone you got to get your Bros involved
with this one I was like no I'm holding
the desserts how do you see that I'm a
dessert holding account and I do not
want to involve myself in some frivolous
activity yeah and so she was like okay
you do 10 push-ups uh Jerry do 10
push-ups and Connor dance why why do I
have to dance yeah I guess because at
first it was like gone through 10
push-ups and we're all like yeah let's
go not knowing that we're about to be
involved right yeah this is like another
10. and the guy's like I'm like because
I didn't the boys didn't know anything
about me yeah I don't know nothing about
this I'm just like boys you got it you
gotta do this for me boys please
yeah yeah so I did the 10 push-ups and
then you know [__] Conor and dice are
like laughing at me right thinking that
they're gone scot-free and then one of
them was like now one of you dance
clown and so Connor it was the weirdest
thing I wish I had filmed this part
because it was it was so it was this
bizarre situation of us and a hundred
plus Thai people around us all watching
Connor fortnite dance
it's like it's like a dream I can't
believe this has actually happened yeah
because it was all it really did feel
like we were storming a castle except
kind of was just Fortnight dancing in
front of the gates because we there was
this one interrogating together there
was this one very small bridge between
like the outside and the inside of the
house that was over a pond right and so
Connor was just by himself on this
bridge it's in front of like a hundred
of like my Thai family just like
fortnite I'm like I'm so glad to do the
push-ups [__] monks just left
watching me and I've got this
traditional Thai dancers dudes playing
these Thai instruments meanwhile she's a
white guy dancing wearing wearing jeans
yeah what a [__] bridge in front of
100 Thai people it was so funny it's a
weird experience yeah but thankfully my
bro's had my bag
yeah I got in the second gear and then
last gate was of course guarded by
Sydney's family uh and they asked me to
uh sing oh yeah uh sing the song that I
sang for my very first dance uh with
Sydney uh which I'm pretty sure I sung
really really badly that's fine but it
did I I forgot to mention even though
you had to do these trials it was it's
normally ended with a with a little bit
of a bribe that's uh oh really yeah yeah
yeah I heard about that yeah did you
know because did you notice like when
they were like okay you're worthy and
I'm like okay thank you and I gave him
like an envelope yeah yeah she bribed
yeah I was like yeah I like this culture
yeah yeah
all I can say is you know Money Talks
you can be the most worthy man in the
world but you know a little bit of like
embarrass yourself and give us more if
you had to like barter like best I can
do is
that happens actually yeah that happens
10 bucks it's like all right eight yeah
I'll take it or leave it boys we're
packing it up yeah spot out we didn't do
this for our wedding but my mom was like
you know traditionally sometimes it
really depends on the feeling of
whoever's got in the gate sometimes if
they're feeling like oh this uh this
doesn't look like enough money
slip an extra like 100 200 bucks or
something like that that's so funny
that's awesome so yeah it's it's it's
it's not meant to be taken seriously
it's just like it was a lot of fun yeah
awful all for fun very casual
um and then after that uh is where you
had like the adult blessing ceremony
which is which is kind of what you see
with uh this yeah so what happens is you
uh you go into another room and the
immediate family all will take a seat
right and uh the basic the basic premise
is every one who is part of your
immediate family who is an elder to you
gets to bless your marriage which uh
every everyone takes one of these one of
these strings gives their blessings and
then literally like ties are not ties a
knot for both me and for Sydney right
um now
uh I didn't know how long this was going
to last because yeah because I was like
you got a lot of Elders at the beginning
I was like you know Joey Connor died as
you know Emily you know come in have a
look and they saw you know both of our
parents blessing us tying the knots yeah
um and then I forgot to tell them that
uh this my entire family who was sitting
down waiting their turn they're gonna
come up and bless me as well so that you
were there standing there for like what
15 minutes or something yeah it was like
15-20 minutes before I was like oh yeah
um you guys go away from now it's okay
because we're going to be here we're one
tenth of the way through right now yeah
so as as you can see
um I mean I I like I like the ceremony
and everything but I'm glad that mostly
it was just my family there yeah
um because uh obviously a lot of
Sydney's family is in America uh because
if Sydney's family was there we would
have been there for [__] hours like
your whole album with my whole um yeah
yeah because uh Hey like everyone got
the chance to give that blessing and you
can always tell when you've been to like
a Thai wedding because this is kind of
like a just marriage uh sorry just
married kind of symbol because you can
tell Southeast Asian families their arm
just gets filled up I was gonna say most
people when they go to Southeast Asia
and they come back they only have a
bunch of bands
right lots of bracelets that was like um
some other ceremony where I think it was
something to do with elders but it
wasn't your dad and then your dad was
talking to me right and everyone was
being really quiet and I was like is it
okay for you to talk this loudly to me
and then eventually your mom came up I
was like shut up
not to me to your dad yeah yeah because
it was like everyone was quiet in this
room watching uh I was one of your
family uh like blasting you or something
and then yeah Dad just turns around and
he goes are you enjoying Thailand so far
and I was like oh well you know like a
whisper
I'm getting the party started yeah and
then like in the meanwhile like there's
literally a line of my elders just
waiting waiting to do it and my dad's
just like we're gonna be here a while
oh my God and then there was the one
after where with the water pouring one
yeah yeah so after I got all my eldest
blessing then we have the chance for
everyone else who came to their wedding
to give Their Blessings as well and so
uh what happens is me and Sydney sat
down
um and we had kind of like uh yeah we
had like a a vase with a flower in front
of us and what the concept is is that
people can pour water over our hands and
bless us for the start of a new marriage
yeah a lot of other things in Thailand a
lot of blessings every we are very
blessed yeah you blessed we blessed
yeah
um and you know everyone lines up once
again and uh they take they take a kind
of like a not a bucket of water but just
a little like vase of water and just
pour it over our hands and you can say
whatever you want
um I was there for me and Sydney were
there for like 40 minutes yeah what what
the the part that I thought was kind of
funny was that like uh I think you it
was your mom or your aunt that said like
you know to all the English speakers who
are there like us was like okay uh so
you all have to line up in order from
oldest to youngest and I'm like I don't
know 90 of the people here how the [__]
am I supposed to know who's older and
younger than me so I'm just like I'll
just wait till the end
guys can all go ahead but like I
remember I didn't know that we had to
like say something to you guys right
like as we were pouring the water so it
got to my tone and I'm just like oh [__]
I haven't thought about what to say to
you guys I don't remember what I said to
you but I said to Sydney I'm just like
thinking what they're saying and I think
I ended up just saying uh have a good
life and I'm like that sounds like a
threat enjoy the next 24 hours
it's like I didn't mean it to say it
like that I'm just like I didn't know
what to say and I'm just like oh [__] I
should have said that sorry have a good
life I was like have a good life what
the [__] does that mean oh yeah no it's
good though yeah but like I'm a [__]
man I I remember during because we were
sitting there for so long just getting
it just getting blessed um I remember
turning to Sydney and I was like this is
the weirdest signing ceremony I've ever
I've ever been to because it literally
felt like a signing session at a
convention except everyone was just
washing my hands so many people washed
my hands this one at this one ceremony
that my hands were wrinkly but oh yeah I
I got the prune yeah I had the prune
hands all the way
yeah after that it was everything was
over and uh I guess that's when the
party started yeah I remember when we
were waiting to this water thing and uh
I was even cut like a little cousin or
something who yeah my little cousin this
kid there's 10 10 11 year old Thai kid
speaks to me in like a Flawless American
accent and he was talking to me and I
was like how do you
how do you have an American accent he's
like oh what's a lot of South Park and
Family Guy and I was like ah how would
you say you were again he's like I'm 11
I'm like all right well if you're
learning American then I'm sure that's
good yeah you're so funny yeah it's so
cool God I'm like I this uh being at
this family gathering being at this
wedding kind of like opened my eyes a
lot because I talked I talked to a lot
of my younger family members uh one I
realized that a lot of my younger
cousins
um they all I was like they were like
initially they were like oh I watched a
lot of YouTube I was like oh that's
makes sense and then I talked to them a
bit more about who who they watch or who
their favorite content creators were and
90 of my cousins were like oh I watch
YouTubers
I remember that because one of uh your
cousins that was uh sitting with us for
quite a while was really cool kid uh
overheard that conversation and he
turned to me and he went what's a v
trooper and I was like no no no no no
you are the last innocent mind your mind
will not be don't do it don't do it do
it to yourself it's like promise me you
will not look it up after this wedding
oh there was this really awkward moment
where I was having a conversation with
my cousin and my uncle was standing next
for him as well yeah and uh my uh he was
telling me about how he uh watches
YouTube and something like that and then
he says that he watches YouTubers and
then like a minute after that
conversation ends my uncle comes up to
me and he goes uh can you explain why
like his he's always spending this stuff
on his bank account I don't understand
like he's spending a lot on YouTube I
don't understand and I was just like oh
no no no no no no no no he's reading
oh no I was like oh no Uncle I don't
know how to explain this to you so
there's this goal right if I did it
wouldn't help there's this girl been
real but they're not real yeah oh my God
but I also realized um I also had the
realization of why I am so adamant on
not taking pictures wherever I go and I
realized this because it's it's kind of
like
maybe like a kind of trauma I already
know what you're gonna say or maybe like
a kind of trauma that has stuck with me
and I this kind of like made me remember
why I hate taking photos it's because
every family gathering everyone wants to
take a photo and there is never there is
never an opportunity to not take a photo
yeah your aunt was going insane yeah her
camera roll must go on for like years
terabytes yeah because uh because at
this wedding I was like you know taking
a few photos and every time ever every
single time I took a photo like three
more aunts or three more uncles I just
like okay can we take a photo as well
can we can we take a photo and then so
me and Sydney were posing for a lot of
the state I mean meanwhile remember
we're in like a full like Thai
traditional suit and get up and
everything yeah Sydney was like sweating
her ass off uh so we were just standing
there taking photos and as soon as we
thought we had a moment to breathe we'd
walk Five Paces and then someone would
be like can we take a photo can we take
another photo and we'd be like yes okay
okay you must yeah if you must and I
remember this was just how it was
growing up for me I I've grown up with
the sense that no matter where I go with
people someone's gonna take a photo so I
don't need to take a photo so this is I
guess I remember I remember now why I
never take photos is because in my mind
I'm like someone's always there to take
a photo and there are going to be way
too many there's always an aunt or an
uncle around the corner ready to take a
photo yeah exactly I get that yeah but
I'm glad you guys got to see my house in
Thailand
because I remember
about that because I remember like you
were like all right so uh you know meet
up at the venue at x amount of time and
so you know we we told the taxi driver
to like take us to this venue and
they're taking us through these like
Backstreets and I'm like yeah yeah where
is this venue yeah and then I realized
your Venue is just your house and I'm
like why did you say venue you could
have just said house and I would have
been less confused because along this
road it was the weirdest Road right
because it's like I guess we entered
like kind of the the nicer back streets
where like there's like tons of like
huge mansions with like extraordinarily
like large ponds and lands and stuff
like that yeah and I don't know if
nothing in Thailand but there were so
many statues of Pop Culture figures on
the streets that was there was a like
that was like a six foot bust of Captain
America yeah in front of someone's house
I had to double take so many times
Captain America's just his like from his
abs to his head yeah six foot statues
and then there was like this like like
maybe three or four foot tall like Mario
like porcelain statue yeah
um I I think it is just maybe not
traditionally part of Thai culture but
just yeah all right yeah we're just
sometimes you know Thai people
especially you know people around me
sometimes if you can just grab a cool
little like ornament or like artifact or
something like that no matter how out of
place it is you just put it there yeah
because I I remember I get a six foot
yeah
I'm like did you make that yeah because
I remember I I told that story to one of
your cousins and I told him about the
Mario one and he was like oh yeah yeah
he's a doctor yeah and I'm like didn't
even get Dr Mario
you [__] up like it doesn't explain
why he has a Mario in the front of his
Mansion yeah I think I think he just put
it like one of my other neighbors has a
[__] Jurassic Park theme yeah gate or
something like that yeah Titus and I
went walking in your neighborhood right
and we just walked past this gate and it
was I'm like I'm not tripping that's the
Jurassic Park logo on the gate and then
I look over at the wall and it clearly
says Jurassic Park and I'm like where am
I
what is Thailand
yeah sometimes uh at least from you know
my family and people I know sometimes
Thai people especially when they're
trying to like build a house or put some
cool things or kind of try to get away
to stand out they would just take a
random thing from America or British
films or whatever and just put it in the
house doesn't match the aesthetic
doesn't match the vibe at all sometimes
you're just walking past the house and
you see a random Mario statue doesn't
make any sense at all but that's just
that's just the way things are just like
like your neighbor's house that we
started that uh the the ceremony in like
looked like every country put into one
place like it was it was there was like
a there was like an Amsterdam inspired
windmill next to a river and then
there's like a very traditional like
Southeast Asian house and then there was
just straight up like a concrete block
that looked like something out of like
like Eastern Europe and I'm like what is
this place like what's the theming it's
very unusual like how did the guy tell
the architect being like I want this I
want this I want this and the guy's like
you want it all in the same property
right like yeah it kind of feels like a
theme park you know because they're just
like oh just so just have a have a
little bit of everything why not I
thought it was a theme park and then
your cousin was like oh no this is the
neighbor's house I'm like what does your
neighbor do
it was insane it was very impressive so
weird yeah thankfully none of my family
served you boys uh bearing with ice
cubes in it yeah I was expecting it
I thought was unacceptable I was like
could I have a beer please and so he
gives me a beer it gives me a straw
a straw for a canned beer I was like I
was like no thank you what what is this
why do they drink beer out of a straw
what is that can you explain
um some people some people just do that
that's [__] up I don't know why what
the [__] beer out of a straw I think
it's [__] up as well uh yeah
I don't know I don't know I I yeah no
don't Zone my guys
that's not my meds I don't think there
was a moment where I like in the 72
hours where I was in Thailand where I
wasn't disgustingly full I think I was
full constantly I think every moment I
was with these boys because I only got
to take care of these boys one at my
wedding and one another day when I could
show them around
um I think every hour I was with these
boys we were eating something because
everything's so good yeah nothing missed
I remember at the wedding uh I think
your your aunt brought out these like uh
like sautes uh like chickens on a skewer
the chicken satay skewers and they're a
bomb dude I swear I saw Connor eat like
50 of those like not not even not even
over exaggerating I think he actually
ate like four full plates of that [__] I
had a lot and they just kept bringing
them over when I was finished and I was
like oh [__] I can't let them get away
see I thought Connor wasn't eating much
uh because I was like talking to my
family and everything and every time I'd
come to cut like your table Connor had a
false uh place
with Satay every time so I just assumed
oh it's the same plate no he was just
eating it so fast but you didn't see it
yeah and even though I was full they
started making other food and I was like
well I have to try it yeah the moment
you came back with the guitar
I was just I was so full and I still ate
a whole kapow
I the question I got the most in
Thailand every every single [__] time
I got any food they were like are you
sure it's spicy they asked me this every
[__] every food I ordered they were
like are you sure this is spicy yes I'm
sure give it to me on the airline or any
any [__] stall yeah a pad thai that
wasn't even spicy they're like are you
sure it's spicy I was like no it's fine
I can eat it I wouldn't have ordered it
if I couldn't yeah but because like Thai
Thailand you just assume everything is
spicy I remember I took these boys it's
like kind of like a casual place where
they serve like barbecue pork and some
chicken and stuff like that came with
three sauces
um and I remember Joey and uh diet is
asking me oh this is this like different
splice levels and I'd been in and I had
been abroad for so long so I assumed it
was just different spice levels and then
we were all like progressively trying
like the three different sources trying
to figure out which one was the spiciest
one right and then Joey was like oh I
think the middle one's the spiciest one
that is like I think the left one's the
spiciest one and then I tried it and I'm
like wait I think they were all the same
amount of spice I think it's the
difference is the sweetness of them
actually which just goes in Thailand
there's only one level of spice it's
just spicy it's just spicy Dom was
sweating non-stop yeah bro he was just
wet the the squid uh like dish that you
guys had at your wedding oh yeah the
spices yeah that was that was probably
the spiciest one I mean you know like
had a kick though but you know I I was
fine Connor was fine I guess didus
really likes squid yeah and uh and he he
put maybe half of his plate full of that
squid not knowing that it was the
spiciest thing dog author he finished it
he looked like he just came out of a
sauna
physically dripping he's so funny I'm
like are you okay did you just like run
a half marathon
yeah I mean because I was telling this
to Joey earlier because I was I was
surprised I think Joey's got you've gone
on like a lot better handling yourself
compared to I surprised myself yeah yeah
because you handled a lot of the Thai
food pretty well I remember I remember
saying I think with Thai food there's
like a perfect amount of spice with
certain dishes people will just make
dishes with the amount of splice it has
that it has and you can last for it to
be less spicy but I think by asking it
to be less spicy or removing some of the
flavor out of it for sure you're also
asking it to be less tasty yeah you're
asking for it to be less tasty they can
make it less spicy but the reason
there's always going to be a little bit
of spice in it even if you ask for Thai
food to be less spicy
um it's because I think there is just a
perfect amount of splice level for this
food that makes it the optimal taste and
that unfortunately is it's too spicy for
a lot of people um so good though yeah
but it's so good yeah oh man I was just
full the whole time yeah
[Music]
uh after about three days three days in
Thailand by the way there wasn't a
single day in Thailand well I did not
have uh the most horrendously spicy food
when when the moment me and Sydney
stepped off the plane we were just like
just go to town just just go to town let
give us all of the spicy food that we
can't get in Japan
um and so by day three my [__] was no
crying dude I I was struggling yeah I
needed I had like I would [__] like 10
times a day every time yeah yeah my ass
was like Mount Saint Helen yeah yeah it
was insane it was so sore and so and so
here are um at my house sitting on my
toilet and I I was having I was having
one of those shits where it was like the
sweats that came with it you know that
take your shirt off yeah
and I remember just sitting down I and I
reached over for the bidet and it wasn't
there and I was just like if there's one
country that needs a bidet it's Thailand
why is it not here right now the spice
they use I'm shocked in their butthole
yeah people just getting used to it is
that is that that poops normal or is it
is everyone pooping like that or maybe
in Thailand the general consensus is
yeah poops are painful right yeah that's
the default I don't know I mean I don't
think I ever got used to it I just fight
for my life yeah you just get used to
like fine for your life we do have a
like a sort of like bidet kind of thing
in Thailand but that that didn't do it
yeah it literally literally
I needed
I need it you shouldn't sniper right to
where the I'm trying to like fully
shower my ass cheeks
yeah yeah exactly that was not gonna
work yeah we they they are they had like
a hose you could shotgun your ass I
needed a Precision sniper right where
the area that was on [__] fire and it
just wasn't there so the first thing I
did was I'm like Mom can I buy a bidet
for this house please
I need it okay in Thailand
[Laughter]
where else did you guys go like what
what areas did you guys so the day after
the wedding the day you didn't join us
we we obviously went to the the big
Marketplace which is which is super cool
I mean like we I don't think we even
explored like 10 of that place because
it's right so massive yeah um but yes we
paid uh 25 for a pad yeah yeah yeah oh
okay okay so we paid that and we were
like all right well let's get out of
here before we get scanned more so we
went to um this uh the seon Paragon I
think yeah the same Paragon which is
like a kind of a mall nearby
um did a bit of shopping there and then
yeah I guess just for the rest of the
night we were just there we went back to
that uh uh bar in The Hangover yeah oh
yeah because when I when I heard that
you guys were staying in labua I was
like oh you you guys are staying in it's
one of the most famous hotels in Bangkok
specifically because that's the hotel
where they filmed the hangover too that
scene at the end where the helicopter
comes on the rooftop that's the bar that
it's filmed at
um and I know this uh because I assume
everything there was horrendously
overpriced
specifically because this is where The
Hangover 2 took place dude we're looking
at the menu and Emily's like I think I'm
gonna get this streak I'm like Emily
that's a hundred dollar drink she was
like I'm not gonna get that drink
the cheapest drinks they had were 40 USD
right yeah we paid 40 bucks for a gin
and tonic and if you wanted to see the
view we're like one drink we'll check
out the view we'll bounce because you're
on the like 65th floor overlooking the
whole series The View was amazing but
you're definitely paying for the viewers
I mean at least it I mean it was one of
the strongest gin and tonics I had so I
guess you know it wasn't worth it they
were trying to level it out but I'm like
it's still 40 and I'm like yeah yeah uh
you know I'll just take a couple of
pictures up here and then yeah yeah but
was was it what was the hotel worth it
no I didn't like it their room was buggy
as hell I don't know dude like our hotel
room it was like if you want to take a
shower yeah it was just like every five
seconds was a quick Time Event because
you just change the temperature because
it would just scold you randomly you
need to keep changing it I was like what
the [__] yeah I didn't have that problem
at all the Wi-Fi was like ass which all
right you know is whatever but uh there
was like TVs missing uh what else uh
they like lost our bags at one point
dude it was like it was a nightmare good
to know and it was so expensive yeah
because I I've never stayed at that
hotel before because it is one of the
most expensive hotels in Bangkok because
like like I said because simply because
of The Hangover too simply because of
the marketing they got for that it's
like that prices rocketed it is a high
price for Thailand it's like 200 bucks a
night yeah which is you know I mean in
the UK they get you nothing yeah that
doesn't even get you an airbag okay so I
was like oh okay I'll spend 200 bucks
again like a really nice room yeah I
think it was going to be like goaded and
it was it was not very good okay okay
they're they're probably a lot better
hotels that you can get for a lot
cheaper honestly the first time yeah we
stayed in this other hotel that was
close to God's house for the wedding and
that was like I think 40 or 50 a night
it was so good it was so much better and
like the bed was amazing the service was
super good and then we ordered room
service and the room service was so
cheap it was like it was like five bucks
for like all the means what the [__] we
thought I am I suck so we ordered it it
was so good yeah it was really cool I
ordered green curry that cost like 180
bar yeah and I was like what how does
that make any sense how are they making
money okay that's okay that's good to
know because the hotel's really good
yeah yeah yeah yeah
um just just because yeah um I have
never stayed in the Burr I've always
like I've always been curious because
it's the most expensive one but the
breakfast was good though yeah that's
about it yeah that's about it yeah I I
don't really think it's worth it to be
honest okay yeah next time you go we
like we go we'll get a different we'll
stay at that first hotel honestly that
that place
like I know some like pretty good hotels
um that are a bit less than liberal but
like even better than the other Hotel
okay I recommended for you yeah I think
I think three days is a pretty good
amount though I felt like I kind of had
especially the food yeah I think my
stomach was like begging me to stop yeah
so I think three days was perfect how
does anyone stay in shape in Thailand
like I would I would be fat as [__] if I
lived in Thailand for like more than a
month dude it's all like you get all the
manga go smoothies yeah and goes
everywhere there's coconuts coconut
coconuts everywhere I hate so much
coconut ice cream dude yeah so good the
fresh coconut ice cream is so good it's
so good that diet is like Dom didn't
even know that it was like coconut ice
cream yeah
the first time he was like I was like I
didn't know what it was like you know
because it's just white ice cream right
and I'm like oh what flavor is that and
he's like I think it's vanilla yeah I'm
like what do you mean you think it's
vanilla I had a scoop and I'm like this
is clearly coconut and he's like he
hates coconut and he hates coconut he
hates coconut with a passion I was like
Don this is coconut and he's like yeah I
didn't really like it I'm like you ate
the whole thing though you're such a
[__] liar how does your brain off
yeah I'm glad you enjoyed the Thai
sausage though that was so good as the
biggest sausage connoisseur [__] love
sausages yeah JoJo fan yeah and I mean
obviously if you ever had Thai sausage
um it doesn't taste like a normal
sausage it's very spicy see very
flavorful as it is yeah I don't know
like I feel like it wasn't oh man that's
the word it doesn't have that like super
nice bite to it that some sausages have
yeah but the flavors of the spices in it
were insane yeah it kind of made me like
like seeing seeing you I was gonna say
seeing you seeing you enjoy that sausage
uh yes and kind of like being back in
time I kind of made me realize why Thai
Cuisine is the way it is just because
compared to you know more developed
countries the meat quality isn't the
best yeah right but we kind of like make
up for that by just making the flavors
so strong for sure uh that's it's kind
of almost the opposite of Japanese
Cuisine Japanese Cuisine is all about
letting the letting the meat quality
letting the quality of the ingredients
kind of like
do that one yeah letting natural flavors
take over time sure Thai is more like
this how many [__] spices can we put
in this get it give it give me more
spices
oh so good yeah I heard uh online before
you go to Talent you weren't supposed to
drink the tap water or avoid ice yeah it
was impossible to avoid ice ice was in
everything they put ice in everything so
it's this is more of like in the river
areas okay uh it's also on the food
stalls in in the food stores if you if
you buy stuff in the food and they have
a bucket full of ice or something that's
probably from tap water but if you're in
a mall or in the hotel or you know the
icicle at my wedding that's that's ice
that we've specifically bought that's
been like purified I mean I thought I
was gonna get hit for sure with the
amount of mango and watermelon smoothies
I was drinking but I was good this time
I pulled the good RNG yeah
every time we'd go to a food food store
and one of these guys would ask me uh
God is this is this safe and I'm like
gonna be honest you're playing RNG uh
it's like but it's banging food It's
banging food but you're about to pull
the food poisoning gotcha hopefully you
get something good yeah exactly exactly
yeah but yeah glad you guys enjoyed the
food tour really good yeah Thai food is
as good as I thought it was going to be
yeah which is good to know
this episode is sponsored by halletfresh
with hellofresh you get farm fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and seasonal
recipes delivered right to your doorstep
skip trips to this grocery store and
count on hellofresh to make home cooking
easy fun and affordable that's why it's
America's number one meal kit and trust
me this is coming from a kid who doesn't
even know how to make toast correctly I
wish I was joking hella fresh now has 40
weekly recipes to choose from so you can
say bye bye to your recipe rut and treat
yourself and your family to exciting new
flavors every week no matter your
lifestyle or meal preferences hella
fresh has recipes sure to please
everyone at your table from fit and
wholesome to veggie or family friendly
you'll always find something even the
pickiest eaters will enjoy and you can
customize select Meals by swapping
proteins or sides or even adding protein
to a veggie dish in case you're hitting
it up at the gym like me you know what
I'm saying gentlemen honestly since I've
started going back to the gym again and
trying to you know build an upper body
that doesn't look like a toothpick hello
fresh has really helped me to maintain
my protein intake because because
sometimes it's really difficult to do so
especially if you want a delicious meal
thankfully hellofresh is there to give
me a delicious and protein filled meal
to boot so go to hellofresh.com trash65
and use code trash65 for 65 off plus
free shipping again I'll repeat it
because it's such an amazing meal go to
hellofresh.com trash65 and use code
trash65 for 65 off plus free shipping
they get a hellofresh for sponsoring
this video back to the show one thing I
realized that everyone in my family
could [__] sing and then every time
me and Sydney went up to sing
washing the crowds just go like when you
started singing because then he would
just scream it was so funny just like
there was one point during the karaoke
night where like you you and Sydney went
up to sing Champagne Supernova by Oasis
yeah and you know you were a couple of
drinks in Sydney was [__] faced and you
both oh really slightly remembered the
lyrics so you were kind of like looking
at each other being like you can cover
for me and I remember I'm just like
watching you know gone trying to sing
and Sydney screaming her brains out and
I look over and there's just about 50
Thai people just
just like the elders you know what I
don't know what they're singing and I
don't know what the [__] I'm being
subjected to but at least they're having
fun
it was so funny I just you know we're
just gonna sit here and silence and he's
like yeah
like is this is this how the song's
supposed to sound or yeah they're like
even from Malay weddings did those
random people are just there for the
free food oh yeah yeah oh no like this
was uh we had about 100 people at uh
this Thai wedding in the morning at
least oh that's pretty small
um that was that's that's a pretty you
guys need to have like a list
you gotta you gotta get an artist which
is why like I'm so like it's it's kind
of a meme now how many weddings I've had
but I'm very glad that I did because
um just that just the amount of times uh
the amount of people I was talking about
even just at my Thai wedding and
Sydney's family is as big as my family
as well maybe even actually a bit bigger
um if we had combined our families and
our friends into one wedding I I
wouldn't have been been able to see you
guys at all right I mean it's it's kind
of a flex right you're the only person I
know who's you know had multiple
weddings and one wife I'm
how many wives have you had one that's
like oh [__] all right cool
[Laughter]
but yeah my God you're both not hafu so
I should have had like five oh my God
yeah oh God yeah that's actually that
was this funny moment where
um I was introducing uh my mum uh to uh
Emily and Dom didus and uh I was like oh
yes
um she's uh Emily is uh born upgrown in
American her family is Korean uh you
know Dom is half Cambodian half American
and she's like oh and Jerry's like oh
yeah like I'm half Japanese half
um whatever the [__] half Australian as
well and they were like oh we're both
there's two hafus and my mom's like Oh
go on to hafu as well and I was like Mom
what
Mom I'm full time what are you talking
about everyone there was like do you
need a tall girl
what the [__] all right guys
extremely so actually
oh yeah dude your mom was having the
time of her life she she like she looked
like she was having so much fun yeah she
she definitely lost her voice at the end
oh yeah yeah yeah she she said like she
smoked like 40 packs at the end of the
night she was like did you guys have fun
and I was like oh my God are you okay
you gotta win like full-time March
had a very very very good time oh yeah
but uh hopefully next time maybe we can
you know maybe we can film a special or
something there next time yeah that'd be
great I'd like to see you guys try Thai
boxing or something like that yeah we
just gotta bring me names that's all
yeah next time you come to my house
there will be bidets for longer days
yeah surely
um I nearly died
I
was filming um
a video right so I had I was filming a
video that day before we got the flights
we got a flight at midnight yeah so we
rocked up at like 6 a.m and then had the
wedding at 10 A.M it was yeah well it
was like we we packed this in oh yeah
yeah and uh well you packed it in yeah
and everyone was kind of like I guess
I'll just join Connor on his flight yeah
we all went on the same flight yeah
um yeah so I was um I was doing a video
shoot in uh in gunma and uh dude man it
was oh boy it was like cursed from the
start so I've I you know I rent cars in
Japan fairly often I've rented a car in
Japan from this one location at least 10
plus times I've been there so many
goddamn times and I you know I just know
who you are now I've been there so many
times right so when you book a car in
Japan if it's winter season you probably
want to just get snow tires just in case
because you don't you don't know where
you're going right and I always I always
get snow ties always and psychos no ties
a rock up to the rental car place and
it's 8 A.M and we're gonna get going
because like our video we're like a
tight schedule we gotta get to the next
place it's about two hour driveway and
uh as we're in Japan one question
they'll ask you when you rent a car is
normally they'll ask you where are you
going and it's normally a chill thing
they normally kind of don't care it's
not like American tea yeah it's yeah
it's not they like sometimes they
they'll they'll be a bit persistent
about it but sometimes they'll be like
where you going you're like North about
cool
just carry on yeah and he's like where
you going uh I've got a good man he was
like wearing Goodman I was like all
right okay and so I showed him where I
was going and he was like and then he
started talking with the other staff I
was like what the [__] was when I get a
gun
what's that
um and then he he pulls out the
Translating thing and he goes basically
just saying you can't take this car and
I was like what do you mean I can't take
the car he's like it doesn't have snow
tires on it you didn't ask for snow
tires I was like I [__] what do you
mean I asked for snow I asked for snow
ties I got the receipt right here yeah
he's like no no there's no snow Ties on
it so uh and I just got like a normal
ass small car I thought okay [__] well
with no snow tires well I I clicked snow
ties right so I was like what the [__]
he said you can't take this car okay so
what we can do is if you come back in an
hour we'll get this car and he points at
this card I look down I'm like yeah this
is that's an eight-seater I don't need
it that's massive I do not want to take
this so we're going down like small
roads either and he's like oh I mean we
can't do anything we can't we can't let
you have the cars right what I was like
fine I'll take the eight seater then
what can I do right I've got to go and
it was double the price yeah and yeah
and I had to pay for it even though I
wasn't my [__] fault so like we walk
out and as we're walking out the guy
starts running
all right what's up he's like oh yeah
there was no tires on the car
I was like what I just lied to you he
thought he I think they [__] up and
they just misread there was no ties on
the [__] car this whole time right
and I'm like oh my God okay fine all
right so we go back in oh my good at
least I can get the car
um and they do something they've never
done before they've they asked me for
like my passport and stuff which they
never asked me for okay because I I you
know you live in Japan and it's given
the zaidu card right yeah well so
normally even with that right if you
have a Japanese driving license which I
do they normally don't need anything
else yeah
um and if you're a resident in Japan
even if you go to hotels if I'm correct
you have to look at this I don't know to
my knowledge if you are a resident in
Japan they shouldn't be asking you for
like passport or zaru card even when you
check into a hotel oh you always do yeah
because if you're a Japanese person I
never get asked yeah right right and
they're not supposed to ask you but they
do good for you when you're a foreigner
even if you live in Japan I don't know
why
it's kind of kind of annoying but it is
what it is and same with rental cars if
if you have a Japanese driving license
they shouldn't require anything else
because if you live in Japan that's
probably your ID anyway yeah right so
the dude started asking me for my
passport and I was like bro what the
[__] I've literally rented cars I live
here like 10 times and you've never
asked me for this [__] what the [__]
he's like whoa is like yeah fine dude
come on what the [__] yeah sorry I get
it it's whatever we're going
and then we're driving and there's no
snow anywhere in gunma there's no snow
at all I'm like well this is it was
[__] waste of time
and then we're staying in a ryokan for
the night and I see where the ryokan is
and it's like there's all these roads
around and there's this big black empty
area and it's just a mountain and our
ryokan is right in the middle on top of
this mountain right I'm like well I mean
how bad can it be so we start we start
driving and as we start making our way
up this mountain it's 50 minutes from
the bottom of the mountain to the top of
the real castle geez wow and there's a
giant frozen lake at the top all right
and so we're driving and the snow starts
to get like bigger and bigger and bigger
and 10 minutes into driving this and
it's it's literally like Initial D like
the like the roads just like this yeah
going up it's like if you if you're
drifting it'd be Heaven yeah you're just
drifting the whole thing right and as
we're 10 minutes into this drive there
is a car that is sideways in the road
that is skid out and spun out right and
I'm like oh okay okay guys don't worry
I'm a good driver I'm good I'm
so we're going up and it's all kind of
it's a little dicey like you can feel
the car is kind of like skidding a tiny
bit here and there and you're like okay
come on come on Carl you got this we get
up and it's fine but I'm worried about
the next day so I'm like we're gonna go
video back down yeah and it's snowing
yeah overnight yeah so I was like oh
yeah
and the car she's like can you can you
back the car up a little bit more in the
parking lot and I'm trying to back it up
and the car just can't move it's like
stuck yeah because there's just so much
snow and I'm like I'm like assume I said
uh it won't it won't go it's not
happening she's like she's like yeah
fine get out yeah so next day we do film
all the stuff and we're ready to go
and we go down and we start driving and
I noticed that like I'm like hey guys uh
don't avoid you anything but uh we can't
stop the car the car cannot break so so
we literally have to just go down this
without fully coming trying to be
interesting
there's a weekend break right because
you know your brakes in the Cobblestone
yeah but it won't slow down Beyond like
20 or 30 kilometers an hour yeah Jesus
so you're pretty much stuck at that and
if you try to stop the Cobble skit app
right because it doesn't want to right
because the car doesn't want to do it so
I'm like well don't worry guys 30 is a
really reasonable speed and we'll be
fine and there's some turns where the
car you can feel it start to go like
this just sliding you're like no guys
don't other guys I've drifted before I
it does we'll be fine I know how to turn
into the drift this is fine I know what
I'm doing I didn't really know what I
was doing but I was like yeah it's fine
it's fine we'll just we'll go slow and
you pump the brakes every now and then
just slow it down don't don't try and
harshly break and then we there was this
car in front of us at one point I don't
know how this car was there yeah and
we're going down this pretty steep hill
and I noticed the car is just like
stopping and I'm like uh okay and so I'm
trying to slow down and I'm like how the
[__] has he stopped I can't stop like I
literally cannot stop the car right and
I'm just getting slowly closer to this
card I'm like well [__] we're like 30
meters away from this car and I I'm like
what the [__] do I do because I'm
thinking in my head I'm like man I can't
stop the car pretty sure if I slam the
handbrake that's going to make it worse
yeah
um so I look if there's any other cars
coming and I I'm like all right well
let's go in the other side of the road
because I I know the choice I couldn't
stop and I want to hit this guy yeah so
I turned on the other side of the road
the car is like uh I don't like that but
we managed to keep it safe we'd steer in
and we'd steer back in it was all
chilled
this dude just stopped in the middle of
the road I don't know why
unfortunate and another car came at the
same time it's like oh I have to hit
something yeah like what do I what do I
hit like so you're driving in winter is
scary be very careful Jesus but luckily
we made it down no problem a little
scary was totally chill good stuff
that's pretty why they wanted my ID I
think I think they were like this this
motherfucker's gonna crash this car
where is this where is this guy going
yeah why isn't he snow tires she's a
surprise it was kind of crazy that's
terrifying yeah but luckily it all
turned out okay uh I think we're pretty
I'm pretty good Under Pressure I think
I'd have a freak out so I'm pretty good
at trying to manage the situation but it
was it was scary still especially when
there's other people in the car like if
I question it's me I'm like this [__]
is fully all insured as long as I'm good
we were going like 10 miles an hour I'm
like we'll be fine yeah if I should all
scare them and Scar them I gotta drive
again he's just like I can drift guys
and they're all just like we're gonna
die
like other than that Carl was like
you're driving fantastic car like thank
you can we just don't talk about the eye
section
what the snow areas yeah so be careful
if you drive in Japan really make sure
you look where you're going because no
ties are good but they can't do
everything yeah I genuinely think that
that road was just like you needed
chains to like oh yeah I was gonna say
like did they not give you change no
that you can't you couldn't rent them oh
and I wouldn't even know how to put them
on I've never put chains on my car oh
you can render but you have to tell them
like a month you film a month in advance
yeah because it's the snow season oh my
God these these [__] didn't
even know you needed snow tires when you
come in so you know what makes you think
they're gonna have changed yeah I I it
was it was luckily the snow was light
enough where the snow tires were fine
but if it had snowed anymore I think it
would have just it would just have to be
like sorry we can't go up there yeah
it's just too it's too bad geez you
couldn't stop it's scary it's pretty
[__] yeah because I mean like I I
went up to go see my grandma
um you know up in Sendai to steep
they're very steep yeah and like the the
town where like I kind of grew up I went
there and uh I'd never seen that much
snow in my life
yes
but like I mean Sendai can get some
snowfall but like the the zole like
mountain range stops a lot in the snow
right yeah like it's a lot though so
like so when I saw that there was like a
good 30 40 centimeters on the road I was
like this is unprecedented like it must
be like this winter has been absolutely
[__] for Japan right now amazing for
the ski Fields but I'm not going to the
ski Fields this season because it's just
full of Australians yeah it's also no
offense Australia
it's also crazy how you you're going so
careful on this road and then of course
the public bus driver will be like
[__] multi-track drifting going down
like it like it is sleeping I'm like
this is [__] up how does he drive a
bus and he's taking this like it's easy
he's like he's like one hamburger like
doing gastro players when I like full-on
steering man it's [__] up I I was
terrified for my life and this bus came
downhill look dude didn't look phased
yeah he was like he's like yeah whatever
eyes closed dog I've been doing this my
whole life yeah because I know I did
notice that like the week before we had
like a cold front or something yeah
dropped like 10 degrees Yeah Yeah like
we uh we had a trip planned to Sapporo
when Sydney's family was in the country
and we had to cancel that yeah
um which you know it turned out to be a
blessing in disguise because they really
we went ended up going to yamanashi
um
a little bit like yeah much much warmer
uh no snow there still very very cold
but just no snow or anything like that
yeah um ended up having a fantastic time
as well yeah another thing I noticed uh
taking Sydney's family around the
countryside
um for some reason okay for some reason
obviously yamanashi I don't think it's a
lot of like foreign tourists compared to
Tokyo Osaka maybe yeah maybe Mount Fuji
but we weren't we weren't near anywhere
like too close to Mount Fuji
um so we went we showed them to a lot of
our you know favorite wineries where me
and Sydney would go
um since you know that's kind of the
area we know best
um and as soon as a lot of these local
Japanese people saw that there were
foreign tourists of course they'd be
scared at first but as soon as they
could tell me the city started speaking
Japanese like for some reason the
combination of foreign tourists and a
few of them that could speak Japanese
they went from Super scared to inviting
us to see like some of the most intimate
parts of their like establishments and
houses I don't know what this switch was
but I remember we went to one with this
one Winery and uh we were trying trying
a bunch of wines and everything like
that and at first they were like oh
sorry uh we don't know if you can try
all the wines you want and something
like that
um and then uh we were waiting you know
we were we were outside just trying the
wine and the owner uh comes up to uh
comes up to me and Sydney
um and you know starts asking us oh why
are you guys here and I was like oh yeah
we live in Japan we're just showing our
parents rounds uh since this is their
first time to Japan and he as soon as as
soon as he saw that as as soon as he
heard that and as soon as he started
hearing that you know we live in Japan
he was like I gotta show you something
and I was like what uh what is going on
what are you buying what are you selling
and then he takes he takes us around he
takes us around behind the winery to
this like little back little shed and
he's just like oh oh this is the end
yeah so so none of this uh none of this
is for sale this is all my hobby and
it's and he opens the door and it's a
full-on like home brew Distillery
he's got this little shed and he's like
I'm trying to make gin this is a wine by
the way uh so he's mad scientists so
literally he was like
[Music]
this is my personal collection of men
yeah he was like he just literally
opened up this little shed he's like so
that Winery is my business this is like
my hobby and I wanted to show you guys
my little hobby isn't just a business
it's a passion
and he just he takes out this [__]
full-on jaw it's it is literally like a
jar no packaging whatever it is just a
jar Scoops her a little bit of gin no
and he's just go Joe would you like to
draw some it's a new it's a new
concoction I've been working on was it
good actually it was pretty it was
pretty damn decent actually
[Music]
made in Japan
it's probably the safest country in the
world to go into someone's shed and
drink their alcohol yeah still I don't
know I mean I would get it if it was
like you know a gin Distillery right but
like I mean I mean like it's like to
give credit to the uh I'm just Clowning
on the whole shed part but yeah I mean
it was a shed but that's just because
you know
um he does he has had he has built a
pretty big Winery for himself right um
and it's one of the most famous wineries
in that area I think he just wanted to
do something as like a personal project
no why not um and just start making gin
and I was just like why are you in it's
beta why are you inviting us into your
house it's so weird that they they
literally go from like I just
encountered an alien to being like Oh
yes you are family for a generation yeah
yeah people are really chill especially
in the countryside we
um we also found like a brewery in the
middle of like middle of the yamanashi
as well that's just run by an
um American dude it's super super
[__] random shout out to abina
brewery I think that's the name um they
just have like a craft beer Place yeah
yeah right yeah oh is that the crappie
that uh Sydney's dad gave yeah yeah
that's right that's right yeah yeah
that was that was in this Brewery we
found out you had to drive up a mountain
up a really really steep Mountain same
kind of mountain roads and he is just
this sounds like he's living his best
life yeah there's just this random dude
that was that just had a bunch of loud
he built his house
um on this land kind of like raised the
family there uh and uh one day like his
mates were gassing him up that there
were no good craft beer places in Japan
and they were like kind of gassing him
up to be like you could do it you could
do it so he just went [__] it I'll do it
myself and he just literally went [__]
it I'll do it myself built his own brew
house right right on this mountain
bruises on a chair and I was talking to
him and he [__] incredible story
where he was just like yeah I just I
just built uh built this brew house all
by myself uh designed it myself and uh
everything what an absolute shot great
[__] beers hell yeah yeah so you can
you can find the most random things
sometimes just in the middle of the
countryside yeah talking around like
finding like run artifacts these exist I
feel like the most in Japan if anything
oh yeah where you just you go to like
the most remote places and there'll just
be this really weird random sight there
yeah you know I mean you know we
experienced that on the the road trip
special right like that [__] Maui uh
sorry the uh the Easter Island heads in
the middle of that like that was
literally in like it was kind of hard to
show in the video but that was truly in
the middle of fall it was out there
there was nothing else around us it was
just there yeah and there's so many like
maybe not to that scale but yeah as God
was saying like there's so many like
either tiny restaurants or like bars or
like where I'm like how the [__] are you
making any money out here yeah it's odd
like you maybe encounter like one person
every two weeks yeah it's like you run a
business out here like okay yeah I'm
sure low cost of living kind of offsets
that a little bit but I'm like that's
this uh still a big pleasure running
right yeah now cheap it is to run
businesses out here yeah it must be for
my word of mouth or something yeah
because otherwise some of these places
is just be like you would never be able
to find it otherwise yeah glad to say
though that
um despite not not despite but
um
or after the first day Sydney's parents
very very much enjoyed Japan and uh they
after the weirdness of the after the
weirdness of the first day the girls
buying everything I kind of like I kind
of think it was a trial by fire because
we had a pretty normal trip afterwards
but after the trial by fire they just
enjoyed every aspect of Japanese culture
that's good kind of a simulated I don't
know if assimilated was is the right
word but kind of got used to it very
very quickly so hopefully your parents
have a similar experience yeah they're
coming on April so it'd be interesting
to see do you have anywhere you're going
to take them like you've already feed it
out or no I haven't I don't know where
to take them what are they I don't want
to go Kyoto but I know they want to go
kyotube maybe I can just send them off
[Laughter]
[Applause]
in April it's gonna be so
soft oh yeah because that's [__]
haunted me yeah I was like
have a few days where you take them to
the tourist spots because that's what we
did with his family but you're like you
uh contrast that with just somewhere
outside in the country maybe yeah
or something like that yeah I mean
April's a good time to drive around
Japan yeah the roads are nice it's
really easy why this perfect so I'm
definitely gonna drive them around
somewhere I haven't decided where
um if you want something close by maybe
like hakone like around there would be
nice yeah I mean I mean you could drive
to yeah you could drive to Kyoto or that
kind of area it's kind of fun drive yeah
it's long yeah when uh winter Onsen with
my father and uncle in law now did they
like it they've they absolutely loved it
they didn't mind getting naked I had to
do a little bit of convincing honestly
like the hardest part it's always the
bit before okay so here's here's the
thing when we're in Tokyo
um and we had to cancel a supper or a
trip yeah they were like just book us a
normal hotel and so they left the
booking to me they wanted just a normal
Hotel I tried to sell them the idea of
the Onsen beforehand and they were just
like it's fun you do have to peer
pressure yeah yeah you feel like it's a
really bad producer Get Naked Now show
me your teeth trust me it's good so I I
did uh did a little bit of a white lie I
was like there's only uh one place
that's open right now
turned out to be a nonsense there were
actually other hotels in the area that
were more traditional without nonsense
but it was all like kind of the same
price I was like I'm gonna go for the
Onsen and uh see where it takes us so I
booked the Onsen and we were there they
really really loved the more traditional
Japanese place I think you know I think
if they if they hadn't experienced that
they wouldn't have known what they were
missing kind of and so when I saw them
really enjoying like the more
traditional Vibes and everything I'm
like I think I can get them so I
remember going to this Brewery with them
and we I gotta got a bit toasted and on
the journey back I'm like
don't you guys feel like a nice warm
bath right now I'm just saying
I'm just saying hear me out I'm gonna go
right now it's gonna be one of the most
relaxing balls I've taken of my lives
you guys can join me no pressure at all
again now exactly and you know what
after uh after a long walk and a few
good beers that sounds like a really
really nice idea so just all it needed
was a little bit of a little bit of
convincing and then why do you do like a
tickle on them
that's how it is let me stick with the
balls just a little bit but uh yeah no
awkwardness at all no yeah even though
it was like you know technically like
family members now no awkwardness at all
everyone enjoyed the Onsen
um and
you know it really does change the
moment you step foot in the water yeah
honestly oh this was worse have you had
this conversation with people like can I
wear can I wear like swim shorts yeah
you cannot wear swim shorts
no you you can't wear swim shorts you're
not allowed do you always lose shorts in
your bath that's like more offensive
don't wear just don't do it like you
can't go in with swim shorts I'm like
why I'm like I I don't know how to
explain it to you it's a it's the
culture I don't know just get your [__]
out and shut up just put your balls on
the back trust me it'll make sense when
you're in all right like don't don't be
coming in with swimsuit yeah an old
Japanese lady will come in and kill you
yeah
I'm like why like because it's because
the view it is like you've got to be
clean you kind of foreign objects going
it's like dirty yeah no it's not dirty
and you probably washed them but it's
not how it works like you can't you're
not allowed okay yeah I don't I don't
come into your house making up rules
about who can go and walk back yeah
follow their rules like I get it you're
not comfortable
I just really
like I do it yeah
I don't know it definitely I don't know
if it is like a mental thing but it
definitely feels a lot cleaner being
naked because I remember when I when I
went back to England I went to your bath
and we went to like one of the Spas
there uh and they have like they have
like very kind of like similar Spas
where it's kind of not just a pool but
like I call it a hot tub yeah because
you're still in there with shorts and
there's just something about being there
in shorts and seeing other people in
shorts that it just maybe it's a mental
thing but it definitely doesn't feel as
refreshing or as clean yeah you know
it's especially when everyone has to
bathe before they can enter as well yeah
I think that's that's also important
right yeah I'm gonna try and get my
parents to go one we'll see what they
say yeah I'm doubtful I feel like my I
explained the idea of my mum she seemed
really against it she seemed like no I
can't do that yeah no no my dad I think
my dad is probably he I think he wanted
to seem chill but I feel like he won't
like it either
yeah if I tell them it's the culture
they'll be like I guess yeah there's
like there is nothing you can do about
it it is the culture just stuff that
like I have to eat this yeah
you will you literally get stabbed by
the sushi chef if you don't finish this
just just put them in a situation when
it onto and just feels really enticing
because as soon as you get them in the
mindset to be like just gas them up a
little bit yeah I'll just be like the
beer afterwards is going to be the most
refreshing beer of your life which it is
I gotta think of new names for fish to
lie to them so they don't know what the
actual fish is because if I tell them
what it is they won't eat it I think
I went to a sushi restaurant yesterday
and they served eel yeah and it was
really really good it didn't it tastes
so meaty yeah and I know that if you
tell someone it's ill they'll be like no
yeah yeah but it looks like and the
concept honestly I don't know how he did
this but this eel looked like a piece of
mackerel yeah on top and I was like huh
just tell them it's mackerel
everything's mackerel just be like we
don't have an English name it's just
called unagi let's just see this yeah
it's like but what does that translate
some of them I know they're probably not
gonna like I'll be surprised if they
like sea urchin because I don't like sea
urchin that [__] well yeah yeah I mean
like with things like with things like
sea urchin and even like salmon Roe for
a lot of people it's like it's a lot for
people yeah we'll see we'll see I'll see
yeah they probably want to go Kyoto
there and I'm again I'm dreading that I
don't I really don't wanna I'm thinking
I might try and be like you've been in
Japan a week now you're ready
I just I Kyoto is a really cool place
but I've only been with them when
there's no tourists and even then it
felt like a lot I don't know why kid is
cool but I'm I just don't think it's
like my kind of place almost like it's
way more my speed yeah
what a weird Leaf feels like a theme
park in a lot of ways yeah where it's
like it's like it doesn't feel like it's
very authentic Japanese experience even
though it's the most authentic thing it
feels super stiff super I mean it is old
school but like it has that Vibe and
like me personally I like the just the
the laid backness of other areas of
Japan a lot more yeah oh no I totally
get that feel because uh actually when
you guys came to Thailand and I was
thinking about where I could take you
guys I already wanted to take you
there's a lot of like temples in Bangkok
right but there's just something about
the vibe where you take you take you
know people were visiting to a temple
and you know the architecture [__] we
saw some of them yeah beautiful
beautiful all gold and everything but
it's just so many tourists so many
people just taking pictures it's just
you kind of like lose a little bit of a
sense of what made this what makes this
place so amazing in the first place in
my opinion and I get that same kind of
feeling with Kyoto as well where it was
super cool to see when the streets were
empty and there was like no one there
obviously bad for the city bad for
business there
um but honestly I I've like I I've
enjoyed just going to some other temples
in Japan where it's a bit more isolated
oh yeah and Kyoto prices are nuts yeah
the uh ryokans and hotels and Kyoto are
so expensive oh yeah yeah so far like
that that whole area though like NADA
and Osaka as well is like they all
Uprising for that I've never been to
Nara and I I don't care about feeding
these deer why do people care so much
about this to be fair not uh I think out
of all the prefixes I've been to Nada
was probably the most underwhelming
because like you could feed elsewhere
okay look like you know as someone who
loves animals feeding the deer it's
pretty hype it's pretty fun especially
if you go with a bunch of people who are
like you know not that good with animals
and seeing them [__] their pants is
really fun but other than that and the
giant uh the massive uh bronze Buddha
statue that they have there there isn't
really a whole lot to do in Nara if I'm
being honest like it's it's kind of
underwhelming that like there's maybe a
couple of like dishes that you can only
get in Nara but it's not anything like
yeah I'm blowing if you ask me like most
if you want the good food you just go to
Osaka and if you want the culture you go
to Kyoto it's like nara's kind of in the
middle of that and it's not really yeah
I mean I I think we've been living here
long enough where I just enjoy just
driving around small areas yeah just
seeing all the weird stuff they have and
just kind of checking that out it's way
way more fun I agree it's a touristy
places especially because we've lived
here and obviously if you come here the
first time you should go and do the
touristy stuff because it's cool it is
cool if you're going for the first time
go to kodo go to nargo's awesome yeah
they're awesome but yeah after a while
you just be like I think I'm good yeah
just yeah just driving around is my
favorite part as well yeah yeah you'll
drive more gone I'm looking for more
opportunities I'm glad I'm glad I got
one you know with this but you know yeah
next time as well next time next time
can't relate yeah so uh I was the movie
the other day that I think YouTube I
like the way you said that like it was
an impressive thing because you know I
watched a movie yesterday
um I think it'd be a movie you guys will
like uh it's called the Northman okay
okay
um I had never heard of it until Aki
told me about it because Aki's been on
this really weird binge of watching
Viking films I don't know why okay uh
maybe it's the fact that she loves
Assassin's Creed uh but like she but
yeah so she recommended me this film
that came out like not that long ago
like maybe a couple of months ago
um like didn't do any numbers at the box
office or anything but I was interested
to watch it because it's a Robert Eggers
film and he's the same guy who made the
lighthouse yeah yeah
um and I was like okay well I like this
actor and like the people and it was
like [__] star-studded like you know
cast like there was um uh Alex scars God
uh who's the guy who played uh Pennywise
and Bjork was in the film which I
thought was interesting I was like okay
I didn't even know you could act uh and
like Willem Dafoe and like you know all
these like I like the lighthouse live
yeah yeah so I watched it and uh it was
the most [__] over-the-top Epic film
I've ever seen in my it was like if you
took the concept of a Viking Revenge
story and put it in a dark souls world
like the the fights were just so like
I've been meaning to watch it yeah like
you know how like you know how like
Eggers uh type of like directing is like
very like art Housey yeah it's very hot
it's very you know it's very
non-conventional right
um which is probably why it flopped at
the box office but yeah apparently it
was a flop yeah unfortunately which is
like crazy because it was such a good
one but like the the fights what I liked
about this film was that like I guess
the guy who wrote the original
screenplay of it is like a poet so all
of the dialogue is kind of written in
this like poetry of sorts so it's not so
it's not so much like uh you know I'm
gonna go you know avenge my my uncle who
killed my father and you know know they
will reap for their sins in the gates of
hell it was more like you know it was
like I will find the blade in the moon
of the knights and like Shakespearean
yeah it was it was so like it was like
watching a stage play yeah but with
these Vikings and it and like the some
of the fight scenes were just like the
most 300 us like fight scenes where it's
just like so over the top so epic like
there's one point where they're like two
Vikings completely butt naked a fighting
on like the top of a volcano and the
volcano is like erupting in the
background they just like slicing each
other this is this is too insane this is
too epic that and and it made me realize
I was like why has no one heard of this
film why is like no one watched this
film because it's like it literally did
feel like like Dark Souls right like if
they made Dark Souls into a movie and
they put something like animals that you
watched it no no no it was uh it was
online I saw it online
it came out last year actually oh oh
yeah
meaning either so I watched it and I was
just like God damn like because I still
haven't seen the lighthouse right
um but I've seen like little bits on the
White House yeah and I was like okay if
this is the same guy made the lighthouse
I'm interested now yeah
um but yeah it was it just made me
realize I was like Vikings are [__]
cool
like I knew they were cool like watch
finland's songs yeah yeah but that's
what I was saying yeah I was like
halfway through this filming and I I
looked over at you I'm like you should
probably watch Vineland Saga because
this this the plot is basically Finland
Saga right yeah it's actually not much
no she's never seen it I don't know and
I'm like you're on the Viking like thing
like go go watch the households like we
do not watch anime
don't let me tap it do not watch
anything it has been zero days since
anime was washed
yeah so um I just wanted to recommend
that film because uh I've literally
heard no one talking about it
yeah it's so I watched a few new films
on the flyby from Thailand as well okay
oh yeah because I I I was just so tired
uh I forgot to download yeah
sorry um got to download any uh anime or
anything like that so I'm like okay okay
God forbid I gotta now go through the
library or films on this live action
films live action films and for some
reason Thai Airways had like the entire
let's say Trilogy of Godzilla films oh
no like the new ones yeah the new ones
oh [__] and I was like
it's kind of anime right
just because it's Japanese
but you know so I just wanted to see uh
out of everything because I'd watched
most of the films that were on the
library so wait so it's Shin Godzilla no
no it's it's the uh it's Godzilla yeah
Godzilla king of monsters king of
monsters and Godzilla versus King Kong
oh no it's just like let's let's
see what this let's see what this
Trilogy is all about honestly not that
bad I had a great time
um I didn't know because I I have not
paid attention to the Godzilla films I
did not know that they had made a
Cinematic Universe for the [__]
Monster films yeah did you know this
yeah I had no idea yeah I just I [__]
love Godzilla I haven't watched it but I
knew that right because other people
talk about it yeah because like
especially like king of monsters was
like fan fiction for like or like
fanservice fully Godzilla fans because
it's like like you had like Ghidorah
come out like my girl Mothra was there I
was like let's go you're moving here
because I was like damn they're bringing
out all the [__] messes what's going
on
just being just one film yeah just
having
um and just you know having that one
film especially in like the western
films uh and there's that be it I didn't
realize that they had made a kind of
like a ongoing storyline with all of
these monsters and then adding like King
Kong into the mix and adding the King
Kong movies uh honestly out of I had a
much better time than I thought I would
had considering I'm not that big of a
fan of like Godzilla which one was your
favorite
probably king of monsters yeah right uh
like I don't know why that movie got so
much [__] because I'm like dude how
could you hate a bunches get [__] get
[__] on I heard king of monsters wasn't
as well received in like the Godzilla
fan base right or whatever or like just
the general movie going thing and I'm
like how could you hate a bunch of
monsters beating the [__] out of each
other yeah it may be I think it just
like lit a certain part of my brains
that I just like oh giant things are fun
yeah giant giant monsters that's cool it
was like Smash Bros with Kaiju it was
[__] honestly right because the whole
gang is here I don't think anything's
tickled that part of my brain since like
the the original Pacific Rim oh yeah
yeah
I consider they always all kind of like
bash your head together films yeah yeah
it was literally just ungo Bunga films
but in like entire cities yeah I gotta I
gotta say the MVPs uh whoever the
[__] construction workers are to
rebuild these cities every time a
monster battle happens because oh my God
in king of monsters every [__] City
gets destroyed my God is there a city
left on Earth that hasn't been decimated
by these monsters oh yeah there's
another film art which Were King Kong
and Godzilla go at it I'm like Carter
just you know conveniently or after like
that huge amount of Destruction then
yeah lost all the Architects survived
simulation it's got to be a simulated
wall it's kind of like how else are
these towns appearing back so quick I
don't know man maybe they pull like an
Aver and like a new you know Town comes
out from underground all right let's
replace it my favorite Godzilla though
is uh still Shin Godzilla have you seen
Godzilla I've seen it I've never seen a
Godzilla film you've never seen a real
Godzilla film just didn't look like my
cup of tea did you like Pacific Rim I
didn't watch Pacific Rim okay
[Music]
your cup of tea I think listen I know
I'm a simple brain individual at times
it doesn't mean it is
I know it is
there is literally a giant monkey
[__] flying around wrecking and
buildings yeah you know and destroying a
giant lizard the only kind of guide you
ask thing I've ever watched is the 2006
King Kong film whatever that remake was
oh the one with Jack Black in it I just
had a Jack Black yeah that one sucked
yeah oh yeah everyone that came out
though everyone hyped that up to Dad
yeah as a kid I remember yeah why is
everyone talking about it okay I I don't
know if I would call it it's ironic but
I don't know if I would can call the
original King Kong Kaiju that's a
never-ending argument okay maybe maybe
so many writer threads I've seen being
like
I thought it was because they always had
like King Kong versus Godzilla and [__]
yeah
um I feel like Clifford the bid ranked
Donna okay okay
like I don't think the original King
Kong films
yeah like their appeal to me is totally
different because when you know when I
watch a King Kong film it's like
something different right yeah yeah
actually really good analogy it's it's
more like seeing Sonic and smash and
it's like he's like the American dude
it's like King Kong he just got roped in
like I I know I like if you ask me and
you put a gun on my head if I I just
said it you know it's like the closest
kind of thing yeah I know I think King
Kong became a Kaiju after he was kind of
roped into the Godzilla like franchise
yeah I don't know
yeah to me like Pacific Rim is still one
of my favorite turn your head off uh
sorry turn your brain off and just enjoy
visual cocaine because oh my God that
film gets you so hot I I always wondered
uh on planes I was like I wonder if the
the airflow crew they like judge what
you're watching if they see what you're
watching they're like that's [__] dog
[__] because I was watching like a Spyro
of the dragon video and someone comes
over to me she's like do you want
champagne
I'm like I will
Spyro watching Spyro the Dragon videos
I'm like they must think I am a weird
ass but I'm sitting in this business
seat next to all these serious
businessmen watching Spyro the [__]
Dragon reviews like they were thinking
like who is this guy why is he what is
he watching so I was also I was also
judging the person in front of me for
what they were watching right we got on
the six hour flight and I shoot you not
this person was watching minions and
Minions movies the whole yeah and I was
always that guy and I was like who is
this guy because I was wondering what
kind of person would watch minions yeah
business class I thought because because
we had a couple of like uh like kids in
the the business cabin that we were in
right so I remember yeah it was the guy
sitting right in front of me yeah I was
like every time I looked over I
just to check you know maybe it's like a
15 year old kid or whatever I look it's
like a 50 year old woman yeah
dead serious face just watching minions
and minions too and I'm like yeah hey
man
yeah champagne to go with mine yeah in
my head I'm like well maybe the flight
staff on judging but I certainly yeah
let me go back to my Spyro videos
thank you very much
why do you watching Spyro one ah there
was uh I had this video no I'm curious I
I like a YouTuber and he did a whole
thing reviewing them for like two hours
you know yeah I was like that's great
it's a great game it's a good video too
yeah yeah very good video I just it was
just kind of odd I thought it just kept
coming over spiral gameplay was showing
on the screen I thought they probably
think I'm a weirdo I just think I'm a
little odds it's whatever it's whatever
a little quirky but now but look now we
know what we need to do I need to watch
Lighthouse you need to watch Pacific Rim
uh well I guess I think like if you
don't like Pacific Rim you just don't
like you feel okay well I'll uh watch it
at some point I don't know when we'll
figure it out specific room is the taste
test okay yeah figure it out then you
can go watch like the Godzilla films if
you want sounds good oh yeah hey look at
all these patrons though
let us know in the comments below is
King Kong a Kaiju oh God
I'm waiting for your responses but in
the meantime if you like to support the
show then hey go to our patreon
patreon.com trashcase also follow us on
Twitter send us memes on the subreddit
and if you hit her face listen to us on
Spotify also legendary uh pictures or
films I forgot the company that owns
this
um you got me invested in your [__]
monster verse I don't know how uh when's
the Pacific Rim crossover coming uh
that's I want to know that now because
like I I'm like I'm not invested in
Godzilla won one flight later I'm like
when's the Pacific Rim crossover I want
to know now let us know all right see
you guys next week bye
[Music]
thank you